thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with the man of the hour who defeated
wesley so with the black pieces sam
savion first of all i want to take your
pulse how do you feel right now after
such a tremendous rollercoaster victory
um
i feel great honestly it was a crazy
game he came at me at the with in the
opening with this crazy quincy to h4
idea but i'm really happy with how i
defended after with h5 which is kind of
counterintuitive
giving him this g4 hook but if i don't
do that he's going to play g4 g5 and
probably just make me
did you analyze these positions at home
or was it a complete surprise for me no
he's never played this i definitely
never looked at this
so let's go through the game uh did you
feel in danger
at any point yeah uh this is the moment
where
for us
uh as you just said it's so well
yourself sam after the move h4
h5 is not the type of move uh that
you're looking to play it is
counter-intuitive but the alternative
allowing g4 g5
is you just get rolled off not pleasant
yes so whether you liked it or not after
h5 castles a7 a6 he came at you guns
blazing with the move g4 yeah i mean i
was really happy when he started
thinking after a6 because
i mean at least he's out of book
or not in his prep
yeah exactly so
what point did you say started thinking
right uh here i already felt like i can
definitely win this game because
either i'm winning an exchange
well it's not either i'm or or what
happened in the game basically he has to
play these weird moves like rip age six
through page two and then his attack we
were our main move was crazily enough to
move rook h5 right here i actually
expected rook h5 bishop g4 yeah and
do you stack or go h7 first that was the
correct way bishop to g4 was a very
important h7 first is
and then maybe knight f4
yeah we
is that the movie we were looking at
knight f4
bishop e1 or something like that
yeah forcing knight takes d3 that's
right yeah so basically i can play like
knight take but bishop is really nice to
me because now if i take and go bishop
f5 f6 bishop g3 at the end yes that was
the internet
deep idea yeah that was the intention uh
just for everybody what we were what uh
uh sam was saying that uh bishop d4 yes
bishop f5 queen d4 f6 and bishop g3 is
how white gets compensation for his
exchange so we were kind of expecting
rook h5 and we thought that what he did
kind of helped you kind of play yeah i
was very happy to see this exactly
although he has an interesting idea with
rook h2 i think after knight takes d3
after rook h2 if i take on d3 and play
bishop f5 which i initially wanted to
play which seems very um straightforward
shall we say yeah
for example if queen takes d5 yep queen
c7 yeah
it just looks like a great position
correct that was uh what alejandro was
i kind of got worried about the queen
sack with queen takes f5
after bishop f5
i don't think we looked at this one
alejandro queen not not here uh move ago
yes no we didn't see that at all
what
sorry to interrupt you there but irina
crush has finally converted her winning
position against riyan who goes up a
match point there
but let's go this craziness
two bishops just were eliminated off the
board rook g8 made what's insane is
let's say i go um
knight g6 yes
he couldn't consider taking this knight
uh
and once again anything with bishop c3
is right it's scary very scary yeah but
this is why i didn't know something
right right yeah knight f4 knight d5 oh
yeah no uh i wasn't interested in this
medina uh would be very happy with you
uh in this case which is why you went
knight yeah just put the net on this in
the center and then 96 comes
yeah and here you were
you you were really cruising and you
found a nice trick with knight e4 two
points if a bishop f5 he wants to play
knight d6 knight d6 yeah or knight g5
yeah and
yes yeah and that was why we thought
one question did you take a look at the
engine
no but i i i
will get there
and we'll get very quickly to this
incredible moment right
if you go back a few moves there's a
nice trap he had uh
here when i took on c5
if i go bishop f5 first
yes
queen queen b3 is his idea
okay and now queen takes c5 suddenly he
has rook c3
and then
yeah
whoops that turns the table safe
wow
wow
oops
yeah very nice that's right i had to
take on c5
okay we unfortunately did lots of stuff
so we'll just wrap it up very well did
you see here i did see so when i
initially played queen a2 i thought d3
wins yes and then when this position
happened i was i was shocked
i saw rook c7
oh yeah yeah yes he saw it
that's incredible i saw rook c7 i
finally found rookie 7 holds
but
it's just amazing how the table is
turning after queen takes d3 here
incredible
yeah
queen takes d3 bishop and you saw
because i was spending a lot of time i
was sure d3 wins it was just re-checking
and then suddenly
bishop's e3 queen c5 wins but what if he
goes roxy 7 first
it's just a shocking brilliant move
wow sam a huge victory for you
congratulations
and good luck tomorrow thank you
well done what can you say